[Music]
everyone welcome to MLA I 100 actionable
AI insights using translation and
natural language I'm sure everybody has
had a night of good sleep and coming
here refreshed on the last day so
welcome and we're excited to get you
started today for our speakers we have
myself I'm Sarah Weldon the product
manager for cloud translation API and
Auto ml translation followed by Olga
better go via who is one of our
customers VP of language services at we
localize and then one of my peers Sudhir
of angry product manager for natural
language processing API as well as auto
auto ml natural language processing and
dua I which is one of our new products
that we launched this week and finally
Karen Casas will closes out a head of
mobile engineering with DocuSign who
will walk us through some really great
use cases for natural language
processing with mobile apps here's an
overview of the session today we'll keep
working through stuff because we have a
pretty jam-packed morning and I'll be
starting us off with our language
insights you might be familiar already
today with Auto ml translation that we
launched last year as well as
translation API which has been around
for a little bit longer time with some
very powerful hundred language pairs of
translations that can be used with
mobile applications to give helping to
go to new markets between Japan and
India or Spain and Portugal this API
helps you seamlessly translate between
content to help your users connect
additionally natural language can do
things like entity extraction it can do
sentiment analysis and even beyond that
so as I said earlier we we launched Auto
ml translation last year and
it it allows customers to bring their
own training data to further customize
and improve our existing translation
capabilities to tailor fit to their
particular use cases and to strengthen
it and in their language pairs we have
new updates that we have continued to
invest in our auto ml platform including
investments in our base platform that
will help other help our customers by
reducing their overall training costs to
make improvements in the training
efficiency that we've found in
observable reduction and twenty to forty
percent reduction in training time which
reduces the overall training costs
additionally Auto ml translation now
supports HIPAA compliance which is great
news for our healthcare customers
translation API as I said has been
around for a while and today is really
important juncture where we're
continuing to advance the features and
capabilities to better serve our
localization providers as well as
streamline capabilities for our
developers so today we are announcing
new updates with a set of features that
will help customers have greater control
over their brand data as well as be able
to do longer running operations for
translations asynchronously
so this allows you to do more file
translation type capabilities and then
finally a translation API v3 which is
we're going to be coming out ahead of
you to we'll be introducing model
selection so for the first time with one
API you'll be able to choose whether you
want to use the best model fit for your
needs you could use our general nmt
model you can use your preach your
existing auto ml custom models that
you've built or you can use you know the
model of your choice with our
capabilities we'll be starting off today
with with batch translations and
so today you can now use your GCS bucket
take files that you have in a source
language say English put that in your
GCS bucket in text or HTML is accepted
and then place a request to your
translation API with your Google project
and request the translation to be
returned to you in the in file format in
a GCS bucket with several you can do
multiple languages and you can use a mix
of our pre trained translation models or
an auto ml model that you've custom
trained yourself this allows you to do a
single translation API request that
refers to GCS bucket and I'm single call
you will be able to do multiple files
multiple languages multiple models all
in a single request and then glossary
which we'll talk more in our customer
session with we localized you will be
able to have greater granular control
over things like your brand IP or
location names or you know other other
specific terminology that is that is
tailored to your company if you have a
small set of training data additionally
to that you want to start with but it is
really important to you so you first
specific terms you're able to use this
with either our pre trained models or
our custom models to be able to have
control to ensure that the translations
are delivering at the right quality and
also to reduce the amount of work that
your human translators need to do after
the translation in machine translation
has come out all of these features
because they are all part of the same
translation API v3 will work together so
you can you can use glossary with batch
you can use batch with custom models you
can use glossary with custom models all
through one API and we localized will
come up and talk about how this adds
value to their customers as an LSP by
beining glossary with these various
cases to reduce the the overall needs
for their company so this is olga barrow
gávea
vp of language services with localize so
i represent one of the world's largest
telescope or in the in the US and
seventh in the world this is a little
bit about us so we have 15 over 1500
employees and damn I should have brought
my glasses but ok I didn't so but I
don't need to read basically oh yeah I
have it all here well I can't see that
that well I left my glass but anyways I
mean I know my company inside out we're
pretty big and what's important we serve
a variety of domains and this is where
the glossary feature that I'm going to
talk about comes in extremely handy
because our customers some of us come
with huge training corpora of million
plus translation units which allows us
to avail of our ml model which I'm going
to talk about but some of us will come
with just glossary or not even that so
we need to harvest the main glossary
from say internet or open source or
translation you automation Association
so there is just a tiny glossary at our
disposal but a customer would demand
domain adaptation or we would work with
customers subject matter experts and
build a glossary so customization is
necessary and I will explain why in a
minute
so here is the scale of our operation
and what I'm going to talk about
it's like opinion portal for restaurants
today or it's like an automatic
automotive company where all they care
about is would say is it a crane or is
it like whatever so here is we localize
for you and this is what we do
and you can see like it's life sciences
today it's legal tomorrow and it's God
knows what day after tomorrow and these
are the services that we provide from
digital sir
and interpretation - which is probably
growing field training data for machine
learning so here we are and this is
where we're gonna talk about glossary
stick case study where we're going to
compare Google pre-trained models which
would be generic models versus Google
pre-trained models with customized
glossary and then we're going to compare
Auto ml models which have trained with
customer corpora with a glossary put on
top of pre custom models and what the
glossary would do for us is allow us to
add even more granularity on top of
terminology selection and then the
languages why did we pick the languages
as you can see we have a romance group
then we have Germanic group then we have
a slavic group and then we have some
more representation from the romans
group of languages and then we have an
asian language so we basically see what
the glossary feature what the dictionary
feature does for different language
groups so obviously we see highly
morphological languages slightly less
morphological languages and then we see
Asian languages which basically operate
on the ideograph level so how did we
rank the languages how did we evaluate
them we have highly trained evaluators
that use evaluation for adequacy in
fluency and then engine ranking a B
ranking based on aro typology and that's
a methodology some industries trend
industry standard methodology combined
with localized proprietary methodology
and then we see better quality and user
satisfaction which in our case where
services providers so it translates into
higher quality and subsequently higher
productivity which in turn translates
for pricing time to market and better
final output quality for our customers
so why customize a glossary have a look
driver driver
and driver would provide services as I
said will provide services across a
variety of domains so do we want driver
too when we provide services to a
hardware software company obviously not
have a look
pin pin pin again services across a
variety of domains do you want pin 1 pin
2 and pin 3 depending on the domain
obviously not now let's have a look at
the models see how and that's Google
pre-trained model with a dictionary
injected on top of it as you can see
dictionary pre-trained models with a pre
trained model without a dictionary
consistently losers - pre trained model
with a dictionary and you can see that's
consistent across all the languages that
were ranked maybe the difference is not
as drastic but the difference is
consistently there and same goes for the
engine ranking across the variety of
error types especially with the
terminology when it comes to both in
domain terminology and customer specific
terminology and when we pull our
translators what bothers them most as
they perform post editing process
terminology is usually the biggest
culprit because when the translator
translates and what the customers are
most sensitive to that's usually
terminology so higher number when it
comes to engine ranking for google play
trains nor a pre train models as you can
see higher number means which translator
is better with the following arrow types
again you can see that a higher number
means fewer errors and again you see a
pretty consistent picture here accuracy
and fluency results now you look at
Google or ml Google or ml rated for
accuracy and fluency and again you see
the same consistent picture
so engine ranking for google raml again
you see the same results whenever the
dictionary is injected the translator
preference and the ranking is again in
favor of dictionary so the summary and
next steps we obviously can see that the
gains in accuracy and fluency for all
the languages using the glossary feature
comes on top both on Google with
pre-trained models and on Google on
Google with our ml so the dictionary
injection what does it do in reality
whenever you inject the dictionary you
refine the terminology whether you are
using Google pre-trained models or
whether you are using Google or ml and
then you're able to refine that and
whether you are able to refine the
terminology when you use Google or ml
yes you train with customer data but
still the training data can have some
ambiguity some translation segments can
translate in certain way some
translation segments can translate
differently but the dictionary feature
is very specific around the terminology
now a couple of things of what we're
doing at will oka lies we still make
sure that we cleanse for named entities
such as proper names such as product
names such as geographical names such as
I don't know location names and then we
also make sure that we're very
consistent around specifying do not
translate and we remove all terminology
ambiguity so it's also very important
how you massage your glossary is how you
massage your dictionaries before you
feed them into the Google dictionary
feature and then next thing we never
just utilize our ml or Google pre
strange models they all just by
themselves in isolation we always make
sure that they are a part of the API
integration in our translation
management system because both Google
pre trains models and Google rml are
integrated in our end-to-end
global content delivery workflow and
that's basically the essence of our
partnership so once all these features
are in place and once we've expanded the
integration to other languages we do see
tremendous benefits again as I said we
work across a variety of domains and our
customers come to us from so many
domains and with such variety in how
much data they bring to the table that
we do see great benefits in this feature
and on that note I pass the microphone
to sadirah who is the product manager
for NLP and she'll continue Thank You
Olga hi everyone hi everyone I'm sadirah
and I lead NLP at Google for products
such as cloud natural language although
I'm a natural language and our document
understanding AI solution which just
announced this week today I'll be
covering an overview as part of this
session for two of our products cloud
national language and auto ml natural
language a cloud national language API
which is currently in GA supports who
various key features a Content
classification API is enable you to
classify content into over 700 different
categories think sports lifestyle
entertainment music so on and so forth
our sentiment analysis API enables you
to detect the prevailing emotion of a
writer within a text passage both in
conversations as well as documents and
we do this at a sentence level at an
entity level and a document level
sentiment our energy extraction API is
enable you to identify commonly found
entities on the web such as Google's and
organization or beverage is a consumer
good so on it support our syntax
analysis API is enable you to identify
parts of speech at tokens and break down
a sentence into its granular granular
tokens today we have two new updates on
our cloud national language a
gie we've added more entities for in
voice pacific entity analysis and
extraction and we've added new languages
to our cloud national language API first
our invoice pacific entities think about
entities commonly found on receipts such
as dates addresses phone numbers
companies prices and numerical values
we've now loaded this all into a
pre-trained entity analysis API
available to you as part of cloud
natural language this will enable you to
automatically convert an unstructured
invoice or a receipt in to structured
data within a matter of seconds using
our pre trained Google model that has
been trained on Google data the good
part is that this is these addresses are
already validated for you by Google Maps
so you can easily pipe the address that
you've detected for instance on this
receipt to the places API on Google Maps
you identify let's say you've found a
receipt that has an address of a
restaurant you can identify the lat/long
values of that restaurant and get
further metadata on that restaurant or
store all of this in structured format
into your own database invoice
processing becomes very easy in
combination with our OCR API you can
easily convert all of this unstructured
data in the structured data using our
entity extraction API s-- second our new
languages you may already know that our
national language api support multiple
languages today we're adding support for
Russian and Japanese for some of our
more popular api's like dart into the
analysis API or entity sentiment API and
our syntax analysis api's let me pause
here for a bit before moving on to our
ml natural language a quick show of
hands how many of you have trained a
custom national language model quite a
few how many of you have deployed a
national language model in production a
smaller percentage well I hope that by
the end of this
you'd be as excited as I am to deploy a
mattre language model introduction
within a matter of hours using our auto
ml national language product last year
we announced or amyl national language a
product that enabled citizen data
scientists to train custom natural
language models specifically a Content
classification model without writing a
single single line of code using a
simple and hiked simple and easy-to-use
interface and the model quality is is
inherently high without any hyper
parameter tuning involved or any machine
learning expertise involved today we're
announcing several new updates to our
auto ml natural language product so we
are now HIPAA compliant our medical
customers or healthcare customers can
easily support content classification
entity extraction as well as sentiment
analysis on any medical document formats
we're also adding support in addition to
our content classification models we're
packing in to more models custom models
into our ml natural language you can now
train a custom entity extraction model
using Auriemma natural language as well
as a custom sentiment analysis model all
you need to do is come into auto
emulation language with some amount of
labelled data these this label data
could be custom classes custom entities
or tags you would like to identify on
your documents or custom sentiment
scores tuned to your own business or
domain we enable you to quickly in a
four step process that's import your
training data click on train train your
own custom model for about three to four
hours and you get an out-of-the-box
custom classification model custom
entity extraction or a custom sentiment
model that can start predicting so that
you can get insights that are relevant
and tuned to your business your own
domain
let me deep dive a little bit into our
or AML sentiment analysis feature that
we just announced today or another
sentiment
nabel's you to do domain-specific
sentiment analysis on your documents or
conversations wise domain-specific
sentiment analysis important one of our
customers Avalon solutions has used auto
ml sentiment analysis to build an
empathetic chat bot now this is a stress
coating app for workplaces that enables
the chat bot to respond with empathy
when it detects stress within a
conversation so if an employee would
type into a chat board it's really hard
right now or I'm really stressful work
or what one day is going really bad
today the chat bot responds sorry to
hear that and this is all working on top
of all ml sentiments so the alcohol
solutions chat bot has auto ml entity
extraction story all ml sentiment
analysis built-in to detect stress
within the conversations so that it can
start responding and starting to create
a more engaging customer experience with
the sentiment analysis feature this can
improve the quality of predictions and
we've seen that the gin the auto ml
sentiment model performs with a higher
accuracy or higher precision than a
generic sentiment model to detect
emotion or sentiment scores that are
very tuned to a conversation or a
certain business domain and it does not
really apply just to a conversational
years case think about document specific
sentiment scores that may be relevant to
detect a sentiment on a financial
statement or earnings statements volumes
of earnings statements are generated
every quarter so we can use all animal
sentiment models to predict analyst
sentiment towards those earning
statements we can print a use or animal
sentiment to detect the market sentiment
towards news articles or on a lighter
note you can also use Auto ml sentiment
panel intended to do sentiment analysis
on musical lyrics
let's say there is a tweet called Delta
I was waiting on the tarmac for two
hours now this is a totally made-up
tweeting sorry Delta you may be familiar
with our sentiment analysis API now if
we were to pipe this into our sentiment
analysis API as you can see the
sentiment score is neutral our sentiment
analysis API doesn't know that waiting
on the runway for two hours is a bad way
let's try to apply all animal sentiment
analysis to make this better now I've
found a data set on Crouch CrowdFlower
that is specific to airline tweets
multiple Airlines are listed and this is
a custom sentiment score from zero to
two zero being the most negative and two
being the most positive so I've taken
this data set and pointed a link to GCS
bucket with that data set on auto
international language all I need to do
is specify that this is the customer
sentiment scale that I'm going to be
supplying all in my national language
zero two to quickly verify that I've my
labels in order and click on train now
within a matter of three hours I get a
custom sentiment model no code involved
all I need to do is check the precision
and recall look at the confusion matrix
check if my sentiment model is confused
on all of these three labels and go back
and tune my training data if needed look
at the false positives and negatives now
as you can see our audible sentiment
model or airline sentiment model knows
that more legroom is definitely good and
losing luggage is not that fun and
waiting on the tarmac is probably not
that fun either
so that's sentiment analysis for you our
third Auto ml natural language model
customed entity extraction enables you
to identify domain-specific entities
within your document now why would
domain-specific entities be relevant to
your business
imagine you have a document or you're an
energy company with oil and gas
reservoir parameters that you'd like to
extract from within your documents our
regular entity analysis API would not be
is tuned mostly for detecting web-based
entities so it may not perform really
well in detecting let's say the density
the pressure viscosity values of a
certain reservoir in the Gulf of Mexico
let's say you have doctor's patient
notes that you are trying to analyze and
you would like to extract specific
symptoms or diseases from within that
within that patient note you could be
and well the invoice example that we
just saw we are able to predict well
prices numbers for phone numbers on and
so forth but they may be specific dates
like billing date supplier date so on of
the various variations of entities
within those documents that you would
like to tune and tag on those documents
or other male entity extraction enables
you to do just that without any code in
wall again all you have to do is provide
some examples and we asked for at least
10 mentions of each entity type 100 for
a good model so that you can start
building a custom entity extraction API
that performs really well for your own
business specific use cases or your own
documents domain-specific documents
let's launch into a quick demo hey today
we're going to talk about how to build a
custom entity extraction model with
Google Cloud auto a mental natural
language if you've played with the
natural language API before you might
have seen that it can extract common
entities from text like the fact that
Google is an organization or that iPhone
is a consumer good but what if you want
to tag more domain specific entities
like types of diseases or the
specialized terminology you might find
in legal documents or patents for that
we'll use auto ml to train and build a
custom entity extraction model first
we'll need a label data set today we'll
build a model that analyzes patents from
Google's public patent
set using Google visions OCR API we
extracted the text from a set of PDFs of
patents here we've stored that data in a
JSON L file which is the data type that
auto ml natural language expects and
we've manually tagged within that text
the character offsets of the custom
entities we want to extract Ottawa
mental natural language expects to read
our jason l files from a google cloud
bucket in addition to our JSON L data
we'll make a CSV file that tells it
we're in Google Cloud we've stored our
data here we specify which data files
should be used for training validation
and testing the remodel if you don't
break your dataset into these three
files
autum l natural language will do it for
you automatically now let's upload our
data here in the Ottawa natural language
interface we'll create a new data set to
import the data we give Auto ml natural
language the CSV file we made and then
we wait importing data can take a couple
of minutes to finish but you'll get an
email and it's done once our data is
imported we can view individual examples
to make sure they were labeled correctly
we can check where and the text
different custom entities were annotated
we can also annotate a new entity right
here from within the tool notice that we
can also tell how many examples we've
got for each label we can begin training
a mile by navigating over to the train
tab and clicking start training training
a model can take up to three hours
behind the scenes Auto ml will do a
neural architecture search to find the
best model it can so now's a good time
to take a coffee break they'll get an
email when the models finished training
when training is finished we'll be able
to see our model here in the training
tab we can see how well it did by
clicking here to see full evaluation
here in the evaluate panel we can see
the performance of our model on
different labels the metrics we'll want
to look at our precision and recall
precision tells us of the snippets the
model labeled applicant how many were
really applicants recall tells us of all
the real applicants in our dataset what
percent were at
recognized by the model we can also
scroll down to see where the model
correctly labelled applicant these are
the true positives and we ran
accidentally mislabeled Texas applicant
or false positives in the test and use
tab we can start actually using our
model hosted by Google to do that we
first have to deploy our model which we
take a few minutes
next we can try to extract custom
entities on a new text snippet there we
go here are the custom entities be
extracted that's all for now
have fun modeling that's excited well
that was the demo with that I would love
to invite Karen Casas director of
engineering at DocuSign who's used
Oroville natural language for
auto-tagging documents let's find out
what he's done thank you
thanks for dinner all right Haga hello
everyone good morning my name is Kiran I
lead mobile engineering at DocuSign and
some Pai fun Kea machine learning
initiatives you probably know doc
assigned today because you used it to
e-sign the important moment in your life
buying a new house or maybe a new car
but today DocuSign is more than a
signature company VR and agreements
cloud company and helping our customers
modernize their systems of agreement
part of modernizing systems of agreement
we are focused on delivering
best-in-class products for preparing
agreements signing agreements managing
agreements and acting on your agreements
as we think about modernizing systems of
agreement we are adding intelligence to
our agreement process to eliminate and
reduce manual actions that's where we
partnered with Google for auto tagging
while I'm on DocuSign I would love to
share a quick story and this this one I
love this so this was four plus years
ago when I started working with DocuSign
one of the evenings I was going back
home on BART and I don't know for people
who are not local Bart is our local
commuter train from downtown back to
suburbs so as going back on
train this gentleman box over to me and
says dude do you work at DocuSign and
yeah I do he's like I love DocuSign I
just bought a home and I signed
everything it was so easy and if you
talk to many of my colleagues at
DocuSign they will share similar I'll or
DocuSign stories and it is such a great
honor to work for a product with
meaningfully touches people's life and
such a huge impact as they are dealing
with important moments and issues of
their life so that's us that's we
whoo-hoo we are at DocuSign now let me
talk about the problem we're trying to
solve today when our customers send
documents out for signing using our web
or mobile app they're to manually place
tags so what is tagging what is this
word tag means tag is a DocuSign term
used for identifying form input fields
where customers can input data and put
and also draw their signatures so let's
take an example there's an NDA document
that I send out for signing you would
expect your customer to input their name
the date they signed the document the
signature itself all these different
input fields are called as tags and as
you can see on the animated gif their
manual tagging can be done we do it
today but it does delay time time to
value and it is error-prone
our goal is to seamlessly identify tags
based on different tag types and
categories and place them on the
document so that user doesn't have to
place a tag move it around make sure
it's properly x and y coordinated and it
is matching the label for which the tag
belongs to so then we thought about
solving this problem and by Kiran why
why did mobile pick up this problem
imagining tagging or placing tags on
this form factor it is it is not fun we
we definitely wanted to make this
process this for my domain it was a big
problem and I tried many things we tried
OCR we try to OCR with custom code
none of them really work at the scale at
which dachshund operates and the
different use cases my customers had all
the different
human types I had none of them really
really worked so the only way to do this
right was using AI and machine learning
so we partnered with Google and the
first question was why Google I think
there are three key reasons I call them
out one I believe Google has the best
best-in-class product for vision deep
learning AI and auto and natural
language AI I do think that they have
best-in-class products there the second
key factor is Auto ml is a very powerful
tool which helps us manage or model
accuracy in performance and finally
partnering Google engineering and
product team was a lot of fun I've being
a engineer myself I had a lot of fun
working with Google team partnering with
them because our scale of solution
solving this problem could not be done
in the first item by ourselves so we
needed some help there so essentially we
had three different models and I'm gonna
walk you through the different
architecture how we solve this problem
pretty soon but we have three different
models first we were we are using vision
OCR we are using Auto ml vision object
detection model and vision our auto ml
natural language entity extraction
models and all these three different
models we trained with thousands and
thousands of documents and hundreds and
thousands of tags that's the only way we
could get the accuracies we are seeing
right now so let me before I actually
talk about the architecture let me demo
and show you guys how this really works
can we switch to demo please so here I
have my mobile device and the first
thing I'm doing is launching our dock
sign app as you can see there's a create
button for somebody to create a document
as I mentioned before the use case is
somebody is trying to create a document
so I created a document I'll load a
document first I'm from us from my local
file directory al pika NDA the document
is loaded next thing and typical doc
sign world any NDA would require two
different people agreeing to an NDA so
we call them signers in this case I'm
have two different test users I'll use
Tamara my first signer Adam the
recipient
in this case I will use Martin so these
are my two different test users I'm
using for signing the next thing I want
to do is load the document and send that
out for signing now as you can see in
literally instantly without user having
to do any interaction the entire
document is tagged all the fields I'm
zooming in all the fields are tagged if
you look at the bottom of the document
both those recipients will need to sign
attacked ready to go and all I need to
do is long press and assign few fields
to Martin and this document is ready to
be sent this in so if you can imagine
like the entire process of tagging very
I had to manually place tags make sure
they're line all that is gone so some of
you might be thinking that's a simple
use case India had like ten fields dude
come on really is it that hard so let's
take a more complex use case I have
another example here so I'm using a u.s.
passport form so I don't know how many
you but I recently renewed our passport
for there at least 350 fields on this
document if not more so I'm going to
take a u.s. passport form load it for
the sake of using a user I'm going to
continue seeing Tamera and now I kick
off tagging and you can see now this is
instantaneous the entire document is
stacked the date the check boxes now
let's go through the rest of the fields
there he goes guys look at look at the
beauty of this all these fields are
tagged the signature tag is tagged the
whole document is tagged and ready to be
sent back to the slides please
so as simple as the demo was as quick as
the demo was that's the beauty of
auto-tagging that's the beauty of AI and
machine learning you can really simplify
and eliminate manual processes that
otherwise would have taken a lot of time
for a normal users to do so I'm going to
now explain how we actually solve this
problem and I'm going to start at three
different levels at the document level
which is simple business for a business
owner what does it mean and then I'm
going to talk about the architecture and
how the models really worked at the core
document level let's take an example I'm
loading a w-9 form I want to use this
for tagging the first thing we do is
extract text the OCR or OCR aspect of
hey what are the different text
components in this document the next
thing I do is identify bounding boxes
for people who have done machine
learning on vision they know bounding
boxes is the technical machine learning
term for tags and sorry to throw another
term on you but they are called as
bounding boxes once we get the results
back from both of them we we process
them to form fill analysis where we
apply more contextual meaning of the
bounding box with the document for
example if there's a sign here and
there's a tag next to it it is a
signature tag it's not a text field so
applying that concept is is the form
field analysis we do and then eventually
as you see on the screenshot by the way
that's coming out from our auto tagging
machine learning algorithms so there's a
completely tagged a w-9 form ready to be
used
the next I'm gonna go to a level deeper
talk about how it's actually architected
a user makes a call to a GCP endpoint we
internally call and app engine we need
App Engine because I'm not making a
straight call to a single model we
actually have multiple models who do
different work so we want to do some
orchestration there and App Engine helps
us do that orchestration the first call
we make is a simultaneous called to OCR
vision model and auto ml a vision of
detection model then the idea of those
two models is extracting tests and
identifying the bounding boxes the
results that we get back we feed
or to the App Engine App Engine and
forwards that request to Auto ml natural
language entity extraction model which
does form field analysis and processing
and those results get fed back to App
Engine where we do clean up why we need
to do cleanup is there lot of times
dad's you overlap if there are two tax
very close to each other so there is lot
of noise and you wanna eliminate some of
those noise and so there's some of that
logic is built in our App Engine site it
returns as hell back to cloud endpoint
and finally we give the results back to
the users so it looks it looks a little
complicated because for for the scale
DocuSign operates we operated billions
and billions of documents and
transactions we had to we had to use
multiple models to come back to come
back and provide the proper results that
you saw in the demo now let's talk about
how do the models really operate so now
we understand our document flow works
how the architecture well the next step
is understanding how models work again
this is a very simplistic view
internally the models are more complex
but just for sake of understanding let's
say the vision object detection at the
at your right at the very top identified
something as a text tag so the category
it identified hey I'm looking I looked
at the document it looks like it's a
tech stack and the OCR model found hey
this text tag is between words saying
sign in favor of okay now the when we
merge the results you see sign there's a
text tab and there is sign in favor of
so this tag actually is a signature tag
so natural language entity extraction
classifies bounding boxes and represents
them in the context of document text and
now the result is you can see the
category of those doc the category of
the tag is signature so that's a beauty
of natural language entity extraction
models so I well implementation of this
is lot more complicated it does take
more time but I'm going to take a step
back and talk about what does it mean
for users point of view what what does
it mean for the business we actually
solve three problems
at the very foundation we are making
agreement processes faster we are
eliminating manual steps it becomes
easier for customers to use secondly
it's once once you apply machine
learning logic it's less error-prone it
is lot more lot more user-friendly
there's more adoption so it's more
reliable and like any other machine
learning project it is self learning and
intelligent as these models are used
more as this model are seeing more data
and get trained more they just keep
getting better over time so that's in in
business view we are making a process
pass reliable and intelligent finally
that's pretty much how doc Stein solved
our problem with help of Google and our
passive actor so there are two walk us
through closing thank you Karen since
launch of Ottoman national language we
have seen applications across multiple
industries from real estate to news
media tribal music energy voice of
customer analytics and we're extremely
humbled by the amount of traction we are
seeing thousands of auto ml national
language models have been built to
classify security documents for GDP our
compliance HR files again to track GDP
our compliance or to classify certain
documents downloads as sensitive
document downloads we've seen various
applications in news editorial processes
we think that we are able to apply
natural language to solve various
business specific use cases across
multiple domains and we're constantly
actually excited and sometimes surprised
by some of the innovative applications
of our technologies our NLP technologies
towards solving real business means we'd
love to get more feedback from you as
you start to try try using auto ml
natural
which please feel free to reach out to
us this is where you can find more
information about our products of
natural language products or or m/l
natural language products and our
translate products we also have a
session on more advanced use cases and a
solution called document understanding
ai a deep dive of that will be available
at 1 o'clock today in one of my other
sessions please feel free to attend that
your feedback is always welcome thank
you so much for your time today I'll
stick around for more questions right
after
[Applause]
[Music]